[Music]
aj is with us aj's in dallas texas hi aj
how are you
i'm better than i deserve sir how are
you doing just the same sir what's up
well there just some background
information i've been listening to you
since i was two and i am 21 about to
turn 22 so cool been a great influence
on my life um thank you quick question
um
my boss originally
left three weeks ago from my current
position and
we work in escrow and i was supposed to
go to the new company with her but
uh
legal action's been taken and i no
longer have a viable option of going to
a new company and my current position is
kind of whoa whoa whoa stop stop stop
stop stop stop what are you talking
about they stop they put a cease and
desist on her from stealing their
employees
i can either confirm or deny that's what
they told me
um
uh
lawyers for the current company that i'm
working on sir
i don't think they can put a gag on
order on you like that i think they're
trying to scare you
okay have you talked to the new company
yes they said they cannot offer me the
position
due to these legal actions being taken
and
because of that um my current position
like i said is hanging on by a thread so
i don't know if i should be scared
uh all right so
walk me through this for a second
because this is so interesting so okay
so your old boss left promised you a job
at the new place the new place said you
can't come because of legal action and
the place you work for now brought in
their lawyers to meet with you at 21
years old and explain to you you cannot
go to the new place because of the legal
action and you can't say a word to
anybody about any of this
yes that's what i'm under the impression
okay find you another job this week and
leave this place
as fast as possible get away from these
people
ah
yes serious that's that's what i was
thinking um yeah it's just i mean i have
a i have a move soon i'm living in my
apartment i was a college student and
i didn't say quit being homeless i said
go find another job yeah
how old are you
21 21 get a return 22.
yeah what do you make
37 800. okay yeah you can find another
job doing that you have a college degree
or not
that's a whole different story sir no i
do not
do some family drama how long have you
been how long have you been doing this
what now
it's coming up on a year in july okay
you work for a real estate escrow
company that closes real estate sales
yes sir
okay
you can go to if you can't go to work
for the same company that your boss went
to you can go to work for another one
you did not sign a non-compete when you
went to work there i'll guarantee you
you didn't
did you yeah
not that i'm aware of sir no i went
through my paperwork i didn't see
anything okay so something about the
other guys stealing employees is what
they're trying to shut down
and so uh the poaching of that
uh and and so you can you know if you
don't go to work for another escrow
company i don't care go to work for
freaking uh target or walmart but go get
a job in the next five days and get out
of there these people are not good
people and aj um i'm gonna speak into
you a minute is that okay
yes sir in this one phone call i've
heard you
as a 21 year old
ex express in a couple of different ways
that you're a victim and you're trapped
and you're stuck
and i want to rattle you out of that you
don't you don't have a college degree
because you didn't finish a college
degree you might have had family drama
that contributed but you you haven't
finished a college degree
you're getting
either a weird shakedown that neither
dave or i've never heard of before
happening with your job cool i'm moving
on
i want you to have this be a moment
where nobody's gonna own aj and aj's
gonna make some license life decisions
financially you're not gonna owe anybody
any money you may get a job making fifty
thousand dollars a year if you start
looking right now using comments
techniques yeah get it you're not a
victim you are a victor go get them man
you know you hear what i'm saying
there's a totally different way to look
at this if you're gonna drag me into
your office and scare me with your
lawyers general walk out the door i
don't need
this almost smile on the way out
yeah
it's just i think more so the reason i'm
feeling so stressed is because i i have
a fiance
support each other we're
living together and
i'm in a deep hole days
because of the family drama house i
screwed myself over you know i shot
myself in the foot took out loans that i
shouldn't have taken out i
had free tuition but like i said the
family drama screwed me over
to where i wasn't able to
accept my fafsa and
no it didn't screw you over here you
chose in the middle of the family drama
to make decisions that screwed you over
you screwed you over take ownership of
it man
i i i signed my name on the lot dotted
line i totally understand that it's not
the family drama's fault it's your fault
what do you owe man so here's the thing
all this stress that you have on you
goes away
if you find a job making forty thousand
dollars doing something else
by the end of the week and i'll bet you
can actually
would you agree with me that if you find
a job making forty thousand dollars all
this other stuff that's bothering you
the debt the fiance the apartment change
all this stuff it's no longer a worry
because you weren't worried about it
before all this
finding a job making forty thousand
makes all this stress go away does it
not
aj yes there's a degree yes or two
degrees well to the degree that it did
before your boss left i mean if you were
going to take the job over the other
place all this stuff still would have
been there you still got to change
apartments you're still getting married
you still got debt but that's just part
you got to fight through those things no
matter where you are
but you called us about these
crazy butt people that you work for and
i'd be running out of there like my hair
was on fire man yeah so go get a job as
soon as you get a job walk in and say um
tell your lawyers i said stick it and
take off man i mean you don't have to be
that mean but that's just that's
basically the message you threaten me
with a lawyer i don't work here anymore
that's easy
done
listen i have never tried to keep an
employee by threatening one with a
lawyer that's kind of like that's
probably just not good not good juice
man it's not gonna get not gonna give
them the result that they want because
that just breeds loyalty every time i
just really wanna work so hard for this
company because they threaten me with a
lawyer that's dumber than crap that's
the worst leadership i've heard and i
don't know when
stupid corporate america and then to
bring a 21 year old and just sweat them
out yeah let's sweat because because
we're obviously going to go out of
business if he leaves
i mean come on
this is just look how big and tough we
are
yeah
at least if you have to let's say this
let's say you have to
bring the 21 year old in and explain
here here's what's happening yeah here's
the this is you don't need the lawyers
to do you're caught in the middle of a
mess i'm sorry yeah and you're not gonna
be able to take that out of the job
because we're not gonna let the guy
poach our company
and so you you are stuck in that regard
you may not want to work here and we're
not mad at you you didn't do anything
but anyway so that's yeah go get another
job aj hold on we're going to give you a
copy of ken coleman's book from paycheck
to purpose and i'll give you a copy of
the assessment to help you do that and
get on his site kingcoleman.com read
everything you can about getting a job
and go get one this week
because forty thousand dollar jobs are
a lot easier to be had right now than
they were a while back and um you need
to get out of there my friend you need
to get out of there and you own all this
other stuff it didn't happen to you
you're happening